can tripe soup cure a hangover we've
created a facility to test the world's
greatest hangover cures and we're gonna
test them all I'm dr. Keller wertham
doctor of internal medicine I'm Frank
Krantz I'm not a doctor but I've been
hung over a lot
welcome to the GQ hangover lab I'm alie
Georgia so then what happened last night
did you guys let each other go overboard
or Fox wine is really a gateway do you
mind if we snoop around and check out
you night yeah okay I noticed the soda
sugar yeah the sugar aspect isn't
necessarily a bad thing we're just
drinking alcohol however the bubbles in
the soda will make the wine get into
your bloodstream fast really you
basically made your own champagne in
weird ways how does it translate what
are you feeling cranky yeah grumpy
I feel very blinky this area of my body
is the least happy I have like a band of
sorrow in the side of my brain we ran
your vital signs you basically still
have a little bit of alcohol you were a
point o3 you were a point o2 we brought
you to our motor skills passing you guys
performed for two quite four on that
would you still like to be cured though
anything liquid I don't care if it's
antifreeze just like I repeat a glass of
something alie and Georgia went on a
bender last night of boxed wine and jars
symptomatically they've got you know
headaches little woozy we mentioned
blinky dehydrated today's hangover cure
that's menudo not the boy bands right I
got that now this is a tomato-based soup
with a lot of rich spice some garbanzo
bean we're just gonna be lime and
and some chilies and peppers of salt
it's if it's a rich rich broth and
there's stomach lining in it oh you guys
believe it or not a lot of people think
this is comfort food my hypothesis is
that the salt and electrolytes are gonna
make them feel a little better and
because of their corn host goes I don't
think they're going to improve there
they're just lost cause we're on the
same page there yeah this is tripe soup
I mean to me this actually looks really
really good
there's a valve oh shut the valves the
best part okay yeah we really have ones
of the bullet there you go it's so meta
to digest a stomach I can't I can't wrap
my brain around it's like an MC Escher
painting you don't I mean you you've
certainly had enough soup for this
experiment to be valid so let's it's
like you're your vitals trying so you're
slightly suicidal 110 over 70 it's not
like that's right where you were before
you guys know what we're testing here is
depth perception focus motor skills our
goal is to suck less okay that's a good
life goal all right back sorry I can't
count that high I think if you counted
not the number of bags we sank but how
much we were laughing during the second
time you would see a definite drop in
grumpy face I was able to focus a lot
more on the whole there were like two or
three of them there was just the one
this time let's be honest the tripe
itself really is not necessary you know
we had to test it cuz it you know this
was tripe soup is there anything to the
hypothesis that maybe our adrenalin went
up with fear and it was almost like like
a shock to our system like our endocrine
system kicked in there there a lot of
those those neurotransmitters and
endorphins that get you know triggered
by a rush of epinephrine what you mean
we were so traumatized by a bowl full of
gastric valves that we didn't notice we
felt like garbage yes that's a that's a
legitimate juror around here she will
try not to see you ever again
it's it's tricky because we're we're not
we're not testing broth we're testing
the tripe
I'll give it a C+ B - B - B - they felt
better the soup was helpful and also we
talked about the distraction factor
there is distraction forget some
adrenaline when you're looking at a
gastric valve and you're told you have
to eat it the things that are helpful in
tripe soup are the broth and the
garbanzo beans and the tortilla and the
lemon so if you stun and scare someone
out of eating the valuable things
with some nasty gastric artery tripe you
really aren't getting the benefits right
I'm gonna have to give it a c-minus I'm
dr. Keller wertham I'm Fran Kranz thanks
for visiting the GQ hangover lab for
more tips and hangover cures subscribe
to the channel and like us
we're not that gross